la crise politique en tunisie maintenant
à l'inquiète au delà des frontières du
pays hier les ambassadeurs du g7 à tunis
ont publié un communiqué invitant le
président queille sayyed a nommé un chef
du gouvernement dans les plus brefs
délais allez pouvoir du président
tunisien des plus controversées depuis
son coup de force du 25 juillet dernier
les précisions avec notre correspondant
à tunis bassam cherish
c'est un appel aux tons de mise en garde
publiée hier celui des sept premières
puissances mondiales à l'adresse du
président tunisien inquiet de la
paralysie politique du pays des
ambassadeurs des pays du g7 en poste en
tunisie ont appelé hier kaïssa aide à
définir rapidement une orientation
claire pour répondre aux attentes de la
population et aux défis auxquels la
tunisie doit faire face un message clair
qu'on pouvait lire sur les pages
officielles des ambassades de france
italie allemagne japon canada royaume
uni ou encore états unis écoutez nous
appelons retour rapide un cadre
constitutionnel dans lequel un parlement
élu joue un rôle de premier plan nous
soulignons également le besoin urgent de
nommer un nouveau chef du gouvernement
pour former un gouvernement apte à faire
face aux crises économiques et
sanitaires auxquels le pays est
confronté et de créer un espace
inclusive de dialogue sur les réformes
constitutionnelles et électorales
proposé le 25 juillet dernier le
président tunisien avait annoncé des
mesures exceptionnelles pour une période
de 30 jours parmi lesquelles le gel des
travaux du parlement la levée de
l'immunité des députés ou encore le
limogeage du premier ministre hichem
mechiche des mesures qui lui octroie de
facto l'autorité exécutive dans le pays
et qui n'ont pas manqué de susciter la
colère de l'opposition à commencer par
celle du parti ennahdha première
formation politique dans le pays une
opération mains propres contre la
corruption reconduite le 24 août dernier
cette fois pour une durée indéterminée
un mois et demi après ce coup de force
politique du président sayed la pression
internationale commence à se faire
sentir hasard du calendrier ou simple
course contre la montre samedi une
délégation américaine s'était de nouveau
rendu à carthage pour demander au chef
de l'état tunisien un retour rapide à la
légitimité constitutionnelle et à la
stabilité démocratique